[Music]
our Justin Bieber and Selena Gomez
proving that distance does in fact make
the heart grow fonder
[Music]
despite rumors that the lovebirds are
broken up or taking a break a source
tells ET that's absolutely not the case
explaining that the pair recently spent
time quote simply apart as they often do
for various reasons the Biebs had been
hanging in California while Selena was
working in the Big Apple
et source adds quote it's not because
they are broken up or taking a break but
that doesn't mean things are perfect
between them they have issues just like
any other couple for what it's worth the
pair did reunite at church in LA on
Wednesday above all else Lena is making
sure to put her needs first our source
explains quote she's still working hard
looking after her health and doing
what's good for her Justin isn't walking
all over her here's what Selena told ET
back in November about her new lease on
life I love what I'm doing right now
it's enjoying my life and I'm getting to
do things that I'm passionate about with
the people that I love
[Music]